jonathan my man how are you i'm good
brother how you feeling i'm good thank
you listen come on
whatever it takes
yeah i understand this is your first
comic con now i see you feel you look on
the outside like calm cool and collected
is the sea and the storm inside or like
how are you dealing with all this right
now what does it sound like on the
inside
big big big movement
slow movement
just happy man yeah
just happy yeah
there was so much speculation about who
your character was going to be when loki
was on and everyone was like king it's
gotta be king and then we got the big
reveal everyone's so excited now your
name
kang's name is in the next avengers
movie what does it feel like to be like
the central dude in this phase
i feels uh
feels cool man you know it's uh
the whole thing is such a uh cultural
the whole thing is of cultural
significance and so to be of
you know titular significance
uh whatever that means
it's humbling actually you know you just
want to get to work you just i just want
to see the script and
start
you know
you know start and
fail and mess up and
you know memorize the lines and and
do all do all the stuff i wanted to do
since i was a little boy in texas
amazing yeah try try again that's right
that's right that's right that's right
clean your plate right on man thank you
so much
you